last week valve released an update that
just screwed up the most expensive
knives in Counter-Strike
or made them even sicker
depends on who you ask prices are
surging people are wondering whether to
sell or hold since it isn't clear
whether a lot of these changes are here
to stay and a lot of us can't help but
wonder what might valve's increasingly
frequent skin touch-ups spell for the
economy at Large
all right so before we start sounding
off about phase two's friendly reminder
that we have a Facebook Clan check out
the link in the description below pug
with me and your friends and other
members of our community climb the
leaderboards win points and buy cool
stuff in the face of shop including
skins okay so if you're not like a super
serious skin fiend and you haven't seen
the changes in question
you're in for a treat last week valve
released two updates that made huge
inroads with regard to cs2's netcode
being an absolute dumpster fire but
today we're talking about a different
part of those updates tweaks to weapon
finishes because by tweaks they meant we
turned the phase two into something out
of the Barbie movie I'm serious look at
this they turned the previously wine
colored with a splash of grape juice
Phase 2 into a marbly neon hot pink
stabby stab oh my God
oh my God what the is that yo it's
just pink it's literally just pink it's
just pink is this a ruby no this is
phase two it's literally just pink if
you ask me it looks
being sick huge buff for the phase two
especially the butterflies and that's
reflected in the price tag which stonked
pretty much as soon as the update went
live that said I feel like most people
agree that the phase twos now go
insanely hard what isn't abundantly
clear is whether the change was fully
intentional like I get it valve
literally said in the patch notes we're
making tweaks to weapon finishes and if
it was a bug they probably would have
reverted it by now but I gotta say this
is like nothing we've ever seen before
since CS2 went into beta the community
has been admiring and in some cases
expressing disappointment at the changes
that Source 2 has wrought upon literally
every skin in the game some were well
received others
not so much but it's one thing to just
brighten up a previously dark finish
it's another thing entirely to just
overhaul a colorway and delete certain
colors and amplify others my black pearl
for instance got a really welcome
facelift in terms of brightness but also
just seems like entirely purple now
what's more finishes like the gamma
Doppler phase three now just look like
an entirely different knife what
Is that real dad is this real this was
so dark before
bro this used to be like dark green and
while I agree that it's a better finish
that yields a better knife it isn't
necessarily fair that people's knives
just sort of transformed overnight which
begs the question what happens if valve
just starts making radical changes to
existing skins a recent example of this
was with the Hedge mazes which recently
took on a stupid amount of knuckleware
even in low floats for those who don't
know these gloves are very very
expensive and Ebbs and flows and their
appearances could really with
people's Investments now mind you valve
has been listening to the community and
have been sort of issuing sleeper
updates that are touching up a lot of
the skins that the community holds deer
blue gems for instance which are some of
the most expensive skins in
Counter-Strike looked goofy as in
the early days of the CS2 beta but got
better over time as valve touched them
up which is not an unreasonable thing to
expect given that Skins are quite
literally the lifeblood of
Counter-Strike and provide valve with a
massive Revenue stream keeping a
dialogue open as to what we want our
skins to look like is great what's
worrying is when just
happens were some of these rather
striking Doppler changes like with the
phase 2 intentional and if so are they
here to stay I'm asking because I really
really want to buy one but I don't know
if they're still gonna look like this a
week or a month or six months down the
road now you might be thinking
so what why are you guys making videos
about Dimitri's buying habits
because they are illustrative of a
larger issue the skin economy has had 10
years to settle into place there is a
very well established hierarchy between
High tier mid-tier and low tier and
while things do change from time to time
and it's good when they do massive
fluctuations are not something we really
want if Pandora suddenly looked like
or phased 2 suddenly became more
expensive than say rubies
that would be bad not just for the
Pandoras and Ruby owners but for
everyone why because it de-incentivizes
skin investment across the board it's
one thing if certain skin stonk or
plummet in value because of changes in
taste Rarity
Etc that's healthy that's how
Investments are supposed to work what's
not supposed to be a thing is if the
market itself just loses all sense of
stability because of just skins changing
overnight every day now to be clear I am
not saying that that's what's happening
here I think we are a long ways from
that and I think that's clear from how
meticulously and intelligently valve
have monitored the appearance of skins
over the past six months or so I don't
think we need to worry about it what I
do think is that we need to be
especially wary of changes like the
Doppler ones why it's one thing if a
newer flashier shinier op like the
goonier comes along and causes the
dragon lore to take a it in price that's
competition
but it's not as if the dealer itself
changed right like it's still the same
skin what you bought is what you have
the P2 on the other hand just morphed
into an entirely new skin one that
arguably looks better than fade or a
black pearl or even a ruby and I would
say that that is not in a word and I use
this word in a market-oriented sense
Fair it is not fair if skins start and
keep changing all mass overnight into
entirely different skins that's going to
Spook people and it's going to make them
less likely to invest thousands or tens
of thousands of dollars into
Counter-Strike Cosmetics long term that
hurts your Investments all of them even
the ones that weren't subject to change
that's the important thing to understand
here anyway again I don't think we need
to be raising any alarm Bells here I'm
only saying all of this because I think
that it's important that we understand
the principles that underlie and indeed
uphold the skin economy we've entered a
very exciting time in the history of
Counter-Strike Skins are booming and
it's great but with a boom comes the
threat of a burst the future looks very
bright and we should all be excited to
be a part of it just be wary and be
responsible see you next time
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit us up on our Twitter Instagram
Facebook and tick tock
thank you